know how when they're trying to Corner
you you're doing a congress you know
you're out there they're trying to pin
you in this one thing and you come over
here and you call this guy you tell them
I didn't say that and then you still
give your message and you stay on point
while all this shits happen at the same
time you can still keep that Poise what
else would you say so so far we have it
Factor Instinct I wrote down naivete an
element of the Tom Brady talked about
the naive factor that you don't know how
dark it is just like I think I can be
the greatest and then the startup phase
what else would you add to it yeah so I
think that is part of being able to read
the base is actually understanding what
the issues are understanding the people
and this is where the Democrats just
fall apart you know they just become
such elitists I mean and and by the way
I want to be clear not just Democrats
Republicans as well I mean when I was
watching uh the Republican debates and
they're sitting here trying to make me
cry for people in Ukraine are you
kidding me are you kidding me have you
looked around America yet do you really
think that this is what the people at
home are going to respond to perpetually
telling them that they have to care
about another Nation more than their own
backyards it's